douze mille habitants est désormais six
ruches la municipalité d'andrésy vient
d'installer des essaims d'abeilles
noires à proximité de la mairie avec
plusieurs agents ils ont enrichi les
essaims le 17 juin dernier
on en rit cherche c'est pas compliqué
les essaims ont été mis dans une petite
boîte en polystyrène que l'on appelle
ruchette et nous allons sortir toutes
les abeilles de des ruchettes pour les
mettre dans leur vraie ruche dans leur
belleruche bien grande
confortable et elles y resteront si tout
va bien
pendant de longues années pour le maire
lui-même apiculteur amateur c'est une
façon de sensibiliser aussi bien les
enfants que les agents de la commune à
protéger cette espèce indispensable nous
avons une ruche par groupes scolaires
donc chaque école à personnaliser sa
ruche et il va y avoir ensuite un
enseignant référent une classe référente
et cet enseignant et cette classe avec
l'aide bien évidemment des techniciens
d'un apiculteur vont s'occuper des
ruches
il va y avoir des séquences pédagogiques
autour de la vie de l'abeille de la vie
de la ruche la ville a aussi lancé une
campagne de financement participatif
objectif récupérer 5000 euros pour des
aménagements sur le rucher municipal les
bâtiments de france nous ont demandé une
clôture avec des règles architecturales
à respecter puisque nous sommes dans une
zone classée et là du coup c'est
beaucoup plus cher
voilà donc on va créer une clôture en
bois avec dessus de la documentation
pédagogique pour le moment la mairie a
récupéré un peu plus de 50% de la somme
soit 2600 euros et pour la première
récolte de miel
il faudra encore patienter un petit peu
jusqu'à juillet si tout va bien